and finally new rule as long as we're
going to go to the trouble of another
impeachment trial
we might as well be honest about what
it's really about
the events of january 6th were a
faith-based initiative
and trumpism is a christian nationalist
movement that believes trump was
literally sent from heaven to save them
it's right there in senator tommy
tuberville's campaign ad
god sent us donald trump because god
knew we were in trouble
[Music]
there's a lot of talk now in liberal
quarters about how republicans should
tell their base who still believe the
election was rigged
that they need to grow up and move on
and stop asking the rest of us to
respect their mass delusion
and of course it is a mass delusion but
the inconvenient truth here is that if
you record
religious faith the kind of exalted
respect we do here in america
you've already lost the argument that
mass delusion is bad
it's fun to laugh at q anon with the
baby eating lizard people and the
pedophile pizza parlors but
have you ever read the book of
revelations
that's that's uh
that's the bible that's your holy book
christians
and they've got seven headed dragons and
locusts that have the face of men and
the teeth of lions and
other stuff you only see after the guy
in the park sells you bad mushrooms
last week the big story was marjory
taylor green believing in jewish space
lasers
which answered the question will there
be comedy after trump
but the book of revelations will tell
you exactly where the world
ends megiddo israel i've been there
yeah that's where all of the armies of
the world will gather and jesus will
come down on a flying horse
shooting swords out of his mouth jesus
not the horse
and have a thousand-year cosmic boss
battle with satan the beast and the
antichrist
it's like 10 avenger movies plus 10
hobbit movies times a night out with
johnny depp
spoiler alert jesus wins after which he
will rapture up all the good souls plus
144
000 jews who were grandfathered in
by oscar schindler
but space lasers from jews
please magical religious thinking is a
virus and q anon is just its current
mutation
that's why mega churches play q and on
videos
it's the same basic plot q is a prophet
trump is the messiah there's an
apocalyptic event looming the storm
there's a titanic struggle of good
versus evil and if you want good to win
just keep those checks coming in
we need to stop pretending there's no
way we'll ever understand why the trump
mob believes in him
it's because they're religious they've
already made space in their heads
for [ __ ] that doesn't make sense when
you're a q anon fanatic you're also a
fundamentalist christian
they just go together like macaroni and
cheese or chardonnay and valium
just me okay that insurrection
looked like a revival meeting with
people praying around
wooden crosses waving the christian flag
and
jesus saved signs yelling jesus is my
savior trump is my president
a jesus 2020 banner hung near the
gallows
that was erected for mike pence because
i guess he's
judas in this version of the story which
makes this guy punch his pilot
it's not a coincidence that every
senator who objected to certifying the
electoral vote in arizona
is an evangelical christian when ted
cruz defended his vote to overturn a
legitimate election
he said recent polling shows that 39
percent of americans believe the
election that just occurred was rigged
you may not agree with that assessment
but it is nevertheless a reality
for nearly half the country in other
words
we have no proof the election was stolen
and you may have verifiable evidence
that it wasn't
but that doesn't matter it only matters
that we believe it
and that's when you're at religion that
you have
that you have to respect something just
because
people believe it does that include
professional wrestling
the founding fathers were pretty adamant
about building a nation based on reason
instead of faith thomas paine wrote a
whole book about it the age of reason
and it was a big hit
it was the white fragility of 1794.
so respectfully i direct you to your own
t-shirt
[ __ ] your feelings
you